this should be better
this should be much better
i i'm moving looks like
looks like it's better i think
my bit rate was like so high like it was
like forty thousand i don't know i would
have never set it to that
i'm running that six thousand right now
and it looks like it's just fine so i
don't know about like
why i would ever set it to forty
thousand
[Music]
but it looks like i'm moving
yeah and it looks like everything's good
hello hello hello welcome back everybody
okay better good thank you diego
bacera
thank you thank you thank you okay sweet
we are good um describe venom in one
sentence
so somebody oh in one sentence i was
gonna say somebody asked me to do this
in one word
and i just said in one word like post
credit scene
because okay like in in all honesty
excuse me
in all honesty
everyone
they're gonna be talking about the post
credits um of this movie um
like in all honesty like the post credit
scene is better than the entire movie
it it is now venom's really fun movie
it's got action
carnage is crazy
woody harrelson escalades cassidy is
crazy
um it's funny it's ritz looks much
funnier than the first one um it
explores the relationship between venom
and carnage or i'm sorry between venom
and eddie uh very very well and i really
really liked that hey thanks isaiah
richardson appreciate that super chat
and what up um
and and
and
that the relationship between venom
and eddie gets explored and it's kind of
weird
some of the things that they do with
venom
but it's different and i liked it but
overall like
it's a good movie
and let me explain if you don't follow
me on twitter follow me on twitter at
cosmic wonder youtube because i talk a
lot on twitter right
i post videos once a day but i talk a
lot on twitter
so you can follow me at cosmic wonder
youtube that's my handle
so
here
here is
here's my rating system
if i ever if you hear me call
if you if you hear me call a movie
amazing
fantastic
a masterpiece
it's like a nine or a ten
right like in that like a nine or a ten
if you hear me say like oh yeah that was
a really great movie it's like
an eight and if you hear me say it's
good
depending on what else i say about that
it's like a seven or below
so i call venom a good movie
i think some people will call it a great
movie
and i think some people call it an
amazing movie
um and i watched it you know to premiere
with other people who thought it was a
really really good movie
and um i i think i i had a lot of fun
watching it and to me
i think if you just watch
if you watch this movie like going in
because it's not like a like a really
big movie it's not like in-game or
anything like that um
like if you go in and you and you
just enjoy it for what it is you're
gonna really like the movie like it's
gonna be a great movie to you
um and i enjoy
excuse me i'm very tired i've done
nothing but fly the past two days
um
but if you do nothing but like just sit
there
and enjoy the movie for what it is
you're gonna really enjoy it
you are because it's funny um there's a
lot of character development as far as
like the connections between eddie brock
and venom and cletus cassidy is
pretty crazy um
like he he stole the show for me
woody harrelson like hands down because
he like
he i mean he's an amazing actor right
but uh he stole the show for me and then
when carnage and venom start fighting
it's pretty sweet it's pretty sweet and
and then there's the post-credits scene
so just go into it
and accept the movie for what it is
right not a big avengers in game movie
not even a real like an avengers movie
like it's venom versus card and [ __ ]
like expect that
expect that expect it to be like super
fun movie um it's got a lot of like deep
meaning behind it it's venom versus
carnage now there is some they get into
some creepy stuff like about cletus's
backstory and i think it's really cool
but
you know
no i'm not a i'm not worth i'm not going
to spoil anything about venom guys i
wouldn't i wouldn't do that
uh
it looks like it is out and i'm ready
for there to be carnage but i have to
acknowledge infinity shades always
coming in clutch
how's it going
great to see you in the chat i'm doing
well
i
and along with mr anderson i am along
with infinity shades i am intrigued as
well let's see what is happening
uh carnage does speak i see somebody
asking that he does have his own voice
um
all right so this is going to be weird
for me because i'm not on my normal
setup so i'm going to do the best i can
to show some of the screen i don't think
i'm going to get it's not gonna be as
smooth as as normal but i am gonna do my
best
but mr anderson if you're ready for that
countdown what if ultron won oh my gosh
that's a crazy title we're starting in
three
two
one
there it is
so let me see if i want to show this
then i have to
kind of undo this
and then do this and then it should be
all right i think that's how
i show it not on my normal setup as you
can see i'm not home
so this is kind of interesting why is my
it's still lagging huh that's
interesting
okay
yeah okay i kind of figured out how to
how to show it but okay
i'll have to okay
there we go
it's interesting that it's kind of
lagging still
whoops okay let's do this
i'm very curious about like
about what's going on with this one like
uh i'm at a minute and five seconds
right now guys
okay okay
[Music]
pop on the g fuel
[Music]
pewdiepie flavor yep pewdiepie flavor
which is lingenberry which i actually
enjoy a lot
um i like toby more but i do like both
spiderman
we have started we're at 140 and we're
in it let's see what happens if voltron
won
oh this is intense
oh this one breaks his heart interesting
well there's the apocalypse black widow
and there's all the freaking ultrons
hey it's hawkeye
that was pretty cool i enjoyed that
hmm
oh that was cool little rockets came out
of her bike
hawkeye's just jacking people up
oh
he has like an invisibility cloak that
was pretty sweet
oh look at that
oh that's pretty freaking cool
oh that's pretty cool i enjoy that
oh he's got a metal arm
[Music]
she just knocked that dude's head off
ah they knocked us
they knocked his arm off oh
and he's alive or
hey brianna how's it going i haven't
heard from you in a while
thanks for super chat what do you mean
you're out
what do you mean no other device
oh i get what you're saying i got what
you're just saying yeah yeah go watch go
watch but thank you thank you for the
super chat thanks for showing up
okay
this is where the end of the world begin
elimination of all life
okay
that was all the avengers is it for
hawkeye and
wow
and he launches all and he's launching
all the nukes right now wow
wow wow
oh that's a crazy scene
they're too late and they're just flying
by all those nukes in the air
oh no his
his wife and kids
so he just like nuked the whole world
envisioned freaking one
look at that
and he calls that piece
oh but thanos comes
nope
it just slides the arrows in half
and now he has the infinity stones
oh and he gave him
whoa
whoa
yo ho ho ho
this is
oh snap asgard
yo
yo ho ho
oh the sovereign
oh no star-lord t'challa everybody
sakar
no not korg
not cork oh
no
oh look ego
well that was fast okay that was like
instant
zandar
dude is there gonna be nova you gonna
show us nova
don't see anova
who's that is that no no that's ultron
who hit him captain marvel
is she enough to beat ultron though
he's got the infinity stones so
oh she's throwing him into the core of
the earth
you have spirit
that's interesting
i already have
captain marvel was probably the avengers
best bet
and looks like she just died dang
okay
it's done at last
does he acknowledge the watcher
he does
he can hear the watcher
he became aware
of me
oh
that's crazy
you have to interfere
you have to interfere you have to
interfere
no
you have to interfere watcher
there's one last hope
and is that black widow and hagar
the watchers like oh crap
so there are the kgb archives
the watchers watching them
do they learn about the watcher though
guys like dude you're gonna make me
sort through all these boxes
so they're just going through boxes
right now
oh geez they're going through a ton of
boxes
oh
look at this
the red guardian shield
oh
the watcher you're so close
zola
intervene then
intervene
oh snap ultron's finding him
show him just intervene
no i knew it
you knew it wasn't going to
this has to be where he intervenes
it's right there
and she finds it
that was my box
he was a man
the watcher did not interfere
but he's in trouble
oh
but the watcher is essentially like a
god he is powerful
oh
i'm liking this episode a lot
okay so now they're trying to activate
zola
oh so he's
so he's alive
hmm
uh
[Laughter]
dialing avengers tower
i wonder if the avengers headquarters
why do i feel like it's not gonna work
oh um
so they put him in an arrow oh and look
his hair
so he's just gonna shoot him into the
one of the ultrons and then
from there they're gonna upload to the
main ultron
this guy about to get arrow to the face
yep and it's uploading
and nat has the freaking red guardian
shield
that's pretty sick
dang
so i was already up
[Music]
that
hr
oh
the ultron hive mind is out of range
because he's in
between universes
classic hawkeye oh that's cool
hot guys just threw a shield down with
his arrows haven't seen that one
that's a sweet move
but bear through
poof
better hurry up oh zolaf is fighting
get him zola
oh it's the opposite
it's the opposite in game she dies like
this and in this one he does
it's gonna blow up
yeah oh and it's like the color of the
soul stone too
that's diff that's that's something
she has her daddy shield
dang
just last climb
direct for interstellar communication
but not you know in between the
universes
he's fighting the watcher
get him watch her
see the watch is like a god he can do
stuff
that's a huge
he's in a universe now
oh snap
he just got thrown into a universe
man i wish this was live action
get him get him watch her get him
watcher oh that's awesome oh that's uh
oh no way
that's sweet
show him what you got bro
that's amazing
you cannot compute the power of my will
that's insane dude they're shattering
universes
holy crap
he's gonna eat the planet
[Music]
that's like galactus
no way
steve rogers is president
wakanda
uh not wakanda
scroll
i'm confused can the watcher die
come on watch her get him
oh what did he just he just disappeared
or
okay
is that the end of the episode
not yet we're getting close though
look
it's doctor strange
i'm out of options
dude
[Laughter]
say it
dad
okay that was an episode here's the
question though is there a post-credits
scene
no post credits soon
i want to see the voices
did i miss it
where's the cast
where's the cast i wanted to see all the
voices well i'm not gonna lie that one
was a pretty dang good
okay
jeffrey yeah
black one is played by later voiced by
lake bell i don't know who that is
and ultron is
by ross
marquand
i feel like i'm missing the character
watcher clint
um
of course there's a ninth episode yeah
that's no this isn't the final episode
there's one more after this
yeah wow
that's pretty cool let's see if i can uh
let's see if chris can somehow i wonder
if chris is in discord no he's not
since we're not home we're not doing an
after chat this time guys
so we'll just spin like a let me take
these off i don't need these anymore
we'll just take a few minutes here and
just talk about what we saw because it
was pretty dang cool
um
wow okay so
it's pretty much like we thought it was
going to be
um
i will say though before we like really
dive into it i will say that i actually
am much more impressed
with the scenes that we got with the
watcher fighting ultron i actually
didn't think we were going to get that i
actually thought i was going to be more
along the lines of like
the watcher going well hey like i kind
of have to interfere now because he's
going to destroy the whole multiverse i
didn't know he's actually going to like
fight ultron so that was pretty cool i
actually liked how they did that
i actually like how they did that so
i mean dang
yeah now the watcher can promote hyundai
that's funny
thriller recap
it reminds me of uh ryan george uh the
pitch meetings
i think it was the inf
infinity yeah it was the infinity war
pitch meeting where he was like oh but
you have time for like a ben and jerry's
like promo or something and he's like oh
yeah totally he's like good because i
already cast that check every anytime i
see something like that that's what it
reminds me of
so
dude that was so crazy how he like
sliced thanos in half just like
thanos shows up you're like oh maybe
thanos can like stop nope
sliced him in half
oh i'm really glad like the watcher oh
man he had that line what did he like
you have no idea the capacity of my will
or something like that like that was a
crazy line i really love that line that
was pretty great
like
yeah
that was like one of those chills line
you know what i mean like
that was pretty good i think the next
episode's gonna gonna really be great
and i'm hoping
like you just you just hope that then
the next episode
ends with like the watcher
like in the main mcu you know what i
mean like
like that's what i want like the post
credit scene of the next episode to be
the watcher like actually turn it into
like the actor jeffrey wright and it's
like
oh i'm in the mcu now and it's like him
talking to like
a different stranger maybe this strange
supreme is the one that we've seen in
spider-man knowing home you know like
he even said ultron said anything is
possible now like because of the
multiverse so it's like
anything's possible which means
i mean it just literally yes that one
thriller thank you you cannot compute
the power of my world that was a crazy
cool line that one got
because like the watcher's a god like
he's a guy he's a cosmic entity right
and the watcher is the oldest
comic lore right
doesn't necessarily mean that's how it
is like in the mcu but comic lore
the the watchers like the oldest species
that can be remembered um and they're
they they have like god powers right i
mean
so
it was cool to see that he actually put
up a fight against ultron and he
actually could beat him right
um
it's like interesting to think about
because like
i get he has all the infinity stones
right
so he can use all those powers but like
could ultron just snap
and like get rid of the watcher
is the watcher outside of those
boundaries like
it's kind of the cool thing but also
like the thing that's like slightly
frustrating so we don't know it's like
what are the what are the laws
of the univ of the like whole multiverse
that we're watching
like
what are those laws set
is the watcher
does he exist outside of universes so
like if ultron snapped would it not
affect the watcher
you know it's things like that that is
kind of like oh man i really wish we
knew that but this episode was fantastic
um
ah man you know
i don't know this is the best one yet
that's a what do you guys say what what
what about let's rate this let's rate
this down below
out of 10 what do you guys give it
but yes there i see some people asking
right now in the chat yeah there's
another episode after this there's like
a big finale
but
let's start to uh
let's start to rate this right in the
chat i'm also kind of curious
i'm also very tired but uh we're also
kind of curious like
why
i guess this has to take place after the
tva gets destroyed oh those are some
high ratings
oh i see some over 10. i got some
i think the lowest
i've seen a seven i got seven and best
yet interesting
so you've really not liked the other one
oh i saw four in there okay
uh yes the next episode is the last one
yes
so i think
ah man
uh no it's
3 30 for me right now actually and
i just flew in
from la from the venom premiere like two
hours ago
um and i'm in a different time zone
staying at not my house staying at
family members houses um so i'm i'm so
exhausted guys so we're not it's not
gonna be super long stream tonight not
bringing chris on
i'm just gonna talk really quick here
about what we can expect the next one to
be
um because i've done nothing but fly and
uh
just stay awake for like 24 hours i'm
like super super
tired uh there was not a post credit
scene i did not see a post credits scene
so now it's like strange supreme episode
party thor episode
and this episode are my top three like
those are my top three favorite
and oh man
man you know i don't
i don't know what that order is the
strange supreme episode was really
really cool i think it's gonna go
strange supreme
this episode and party thor those are my
top three so far i uh
i think uh yeah the hit monkey hulu show
yeah the animated show yeah it's gonna
be like
rated mature or whatever yeah i did peep
the
president america right i uh
president captain america i like
president america right uh
i i questioned what his title would be
because it's like oh captain america but
that's like
kind of a nickname giving it to him
because we're it's captain rogers right
so president rogers president america i
guess that would work i guess that works
um
yeah that was cool there was that one
part where like um
ultron was like galactus which was
pretty cool i i i got a kick out of that
i thought that was i thought that was
pretty cool i thought it was really
really really cool
um yeah so i think yeah it's not james
spader it wasn't james spader i could
i could kind of tell at some point and i
was just kind of like
i don't think it's james spader and then
i looked after her so i was just kind of
like
yeah
yeah yeah so
it's gonna be
the watcher and i'm gonna call him like
like
he's gonna be the watcher
black widow and zola
and then the watch is going to pull in
other people from
other universes like strange supreme and
that's going to be our big final thing
for
the next episode which is going to be
last episode and
i'm actually really excited for it i'm
not going to lie the first
half
of what if didn't really do anything for
me um i thought it's fun i thought it's
a cool idea some episodes were enjoyable
but i i wasn't really invested i was
just kind of like i'm you know i'm
watching it because i love marvel and i
do enjoy the episodes but like
i wasn't that invested and i think it's
because
there like there wasn't necessarily
consequences
or repercussions because
it's animated and yes they did say it's
like retconned mcu like it is cannon to
the mcu but even then i'm still just
kind of like well
i don't know it doesn't seem
like how you know what i mean but now
i'm like yeah i'm um i think it's ending
very very strongly
um and there is going to be a second
season of what if
that's already confirmed
so
i do think the last episode the next
episode that we're going to get is
actually going to link us to the
multiverse madness somehow and
i question on whether or not this
strange supreme is like something we'll
see
in multiverse madness or even spiderman
way home because remember a lot of
people are like oh what's the deal with
strange i think it's just a normal
strange
i think we're gonna see the
the arrogant strange right um
so i don't think he's like mephisto or
anything like that
but
i think we're in for for a pretty big
treat here i i think
i think next episode's gonna be good and
i'm hoping there's a great ending that
connects it or if not a post-credits
team that connects it
hey isaiah thanks for another super chat
if what if follows the same six hour
model of other disney plus shows then
perhaps the last episode will be 90
minutes certainly t'challa is coming
back for one more episode he recorded
multiversal war um
i don't think it's going to be 90
minutes i think it might be
60 minutes because all of these have
only been a half an hour
and all of the other shows we had at
least gotten like a 45 minute episode 50
minute episode something like that right
um these have pretty much stick stuck to
30 minutes give or take five minutes
right
so
28 minutes to 35 minutes um
so really i
i don't think it's going to be that long
i i hoping it's at least an hour long
next time or
i mean no i hope it's at least an hour
long because i think there's a lot of
things that they could do with it but i
mean that action between the watcher
and ultron was pretty dang cool like
i actually really really really like
that so
i think
we have to see we have to who's in that
like they did the like hyundai
commercial right like the multiversal
world dude so who's in that it's like
uh thanos gamora
and t'challa star-lord was in that as
well and then i do believe it was like
uh what did they call apocalypse black
widow
i can't remember
[Music]
i can't remember who else is in that
promo
but there there's a scene that we
haven't seen yet i see some people
asking about 10 episodes there was
supposed to be 10 originally
they cut one out
i don't remember why
but it's done
um
and that was actually really confusing
to me because when i was like attending
the press conference one of the
producers brad winterbomb said 10
episodes and then everyone's like oh
there's only nine like a week later i'm
like how so they kind of cut one and
apparently it was a funny episode though
so nothing like serious but the next
episode is the last episode
um that
wrestling
bum thanks for the super chat hey does
the fight match up with king and wanda
scene
um that's a great question
and i was just thinking
that
this is something that like the tva
would definitely interfere with right so
i even posed the question i think like
during this whole thing i was like you
know the tva would stop ultron
plus they have the ability to make the
infinity stones pretty much useless so i
think this is after
the tba kind of gets taken down although
you know
i still have the question like the tva
technically still out is out there
they're controlled by king now so
i don't know that's that's like a thing
that
i don't know if we're ever gonna get an
answer to
or if we do it's all gonna come together
later on down the road
but um
i think the tva are kind of out for the
count right now because i think they
would interfere
you know what i mean like the whole not
just universal like the multiverses at
stake that's something the tva this is
like
well actually now that i think about it
since the multiverse exists that means
the tva is not there doing their job
because the whole entire point of the
tva
is to make a multiverse not exist right
one sacred timeline so this is probably
after kang
after one of vision after kang
after loki so i
i think i think it's after because that
just makes sense right
because there's there's a lot of
different branches which means the
multiverse is real so
dang um
no i don't think there are 10 episodes
guys a lot of people are saying oh
there's still 10 episodes
nine they got rid of one if there are
ten
i would be very very surprised very
pleasantly surprised because i'm pretty
sure there's only
there's only 10. um
but
i thought this was an incredible episode
um
definitely
top three so my top two like i think
it's my second favorite i still think
strange supreme takes it for me because
there's a lot of different layers that i
like that episode this one actually
brought back strange supreme which is
kind of like
that was cool and i think the next
episode is going to be all of our
favorites i'm hoping i hope they end it
well and i hope they connect it so
dang this is pretty cool but guys as you
can see i am not home i am traveling
last night i was in la for the venom
premiere i landed about two hours ago
here um to see some family members
because my brother had a baby so i'm
here to see the baby and then i fly back
home in a few days so i'm just
completely exhausted but i greatly
appreciate everybody stopping by for the
stream of course i'll be here well i'll
be home for a live stream next week
and we'll have talks about it and we'll
dive into it of course we're gonna
theorize what it all means for
multiverse madness it's gonna be a great
discussion so i hope to see you guys
back here next week chris will
definitely be on from cosmic culture
might even have the real rejects if
they're not too busy filming their
reaction
it's going to be a fun time going to be
a fun time so
i appreciate you all coming out tonight
appreciate everybody who just watched
appreciate everybody who chatted and i
appreciate the super chats of course big
shout out to mr anderson as always for
being an awesome moderator it's just him
and he does an amazing job um
thank you
goofball
thank you everybody who's saying
congratulations i i appreciate all that
but yes uh it's time for me to get some
rest but i love you all you're awesome
i'm gonna do breakdown of this episode i
know i haven't done breakdowns of
everyone but i will do a breakdown of
this one after i get some sleep so i
will see you all on the next live stream
you can catch my video coming out
tomorrow after i rest up but love you
all see